Zach Strief the play-by-play announcer
for the Saints radio network and I'll
start with this one Zach but tell me
like that those waning moments of last
week's game do you still get nervous as
a former player who played for the
Saints won a championship with the
Saints do you still get a little nervous
as you're up there make commenting on
the game yeah absolutely I think you
know for what first of all thanks for
having me Kirk sorry no you know yeah I
think you know I have such close
personal relationships with so many guys
on the field that you know you want to
see them win you want to see them
succeed and certainly I still feel
invested in this team you know I got to
play with the Saints for 12 years and so
I'm just a few months removed so I still
feel like I'm a part of it and I
certainly get a little amped up in some
of those moments but you're still to me
you can still play I've seen you you
look like you can still play but how did
this opportunity really come about
because we know how difficult it is just
to be an analyst I'm an analyst but when
you do the play-by-play role that's
totally different were you practicing
for this role were you doing things
outside of football or this was
something that you always wanted to do
was be the play-by-play guy well I I
almost wish that I had a better story
here but I retired in monk after 12
years it was something that I kind of
knew going into the season that I was
going to be finished and really what
happened was I was taking a bunch of
interviews with local media just to see
what was available kind of one of those
deals arts just you know let's see
everything that really exists out there
and try to figure out if there's
something I would like to do I wasn't
real interested in being an analyst so I
met with a local radio station
difficulty L which is the home station
for the Saints radio network and we sat
down we talked for a while they kind of
brought up a bunch of other stuff and in
sort of walking out the door they were
like you know so much this business is
availability and what's available and
what's open and you know we really don't
have anything open right now but we'd
love to have you involved you know the
only thing we're really searching for is
play-by-play because Jim had retired and
in February and they kind of told me you
know but that's not like a player job
and so I kind of shook my head and I
left the office at that time I got to my
I felt like that was the only thing that
I had been that that I talked to anybody
about over this couple of weeks that I
had real interest in I think mostly
because of what Jim status was as a
play-by-play guy 32 years for the Saints
a really iconic and I think I realized
what a big hole the the play-by-play
voice of a team really has with that
organization and seeing as I love the
organization I saw it as a way to still
be involved in it in a really special
and unique way exact Streif he's the
radio play-by-play announcer for the New
Orleans Saints and look step into big
shoes obviously but doing a terrific job
by the way but the way this season has
kind of gone for the New Orleans Saints
after the way that it ended last year's
act not the way that they possibly
probably wanted to end in Minnesota on
the play I know Marcus Williams he can
have that one back but how do you
describe this season so far up into this
point after the way that it ended a year
ago I think and you know I it's funny in
those really awful kind of devastating
moments like last Minnesota was and I
think yeah it's probably a bit of an
understatement to say that market swishy
have hit back pretty rough deal
certainly for him and for the entire
team and the city but I kind of tweeted
out after that game I got hammered for
it at the time but that you know moments
like those bill champions and and that
those really heartbreaking moments not
only in sports but in your life give you
an opportunity to respond in a unique
way with the unique motivation that
maybe you otherwise wouldn't have and I
think if you watch the Saints team
closely throughout this year that play
kind of comes back into the fold
quite often because if there's one thing
that I would tell you that this team has
excelled in this year it's closing out
games they have found ways week after
week to close games out that may be
going into a drive look you know a
little dim you look at the the Eagles
game this week which I honestly don't
even think is a great example because
that defense essentially shut them down
for three quarters but you take a look
back at the Steelers game the Steelers
offense moving the ball pretty much it
will the fourth quarter is too
fumble recoveries in a turnover on downs
that happened all season long and I
think that comes from you know that
growth that you have as a team when you
go through a situation like they did in
Minnesota I think it served them well
and really I think it's the reason that
they're sitting in the position they are
you know Zach one of the things I which
I I saw this offseason I thought was
really cool was you and your
appreciation for the quarterback of the
Saints Drew Brees
you both got there in 2006 together and
what you guys were able to do a couple
conference championships appearance is a
Super Bowl well what have you seen from
Drew Brees since the day you got to New
Orleans and were drafted to where he's
at now what do people like myself who
are not in the organization what do we
don't know about me what don't we know
about Drew Brees and what you see on a
day-to-day well first of all I never
imagined when that press conference
started that like my crying those tear
ducts they they they opened up and you
are alone man but certainly a moment
that I was glad to have the outcome I
need to do and you know I think what it
is is this for offensive lineman I think
that your success kind of runs through
other people and you build bonds with
guys because I feel like you get
invested in them and certainly nobody
more so for an offensive lineman than
their quarterback and you know the kind
of a unique situation at being not only
one team for 12 years but to have the
same coach in the same quarterback and
so that investment you know for me at
that point had been going on for a long
time and the thing about Drew Brees that
makes him I think special and unique is
that there's never a point and there was
never a time in in my career that I
didn't feel like he had my back you know
I wasn't a starter my whole career I
certainly wasn't a high draft pick you
know I was her backup for five seasons
and there would be games where you know
I had to play and you know my first
start as a rookie was against Simeon
rice
if you're the quarterback and you have a
seventh round you know rookie offensive
lineman that quite honestly doesn't have
a ton of physical ability in Simeon
Rice's the guys you could imagine a
little bit of trepidation but there was
no point in that week I mean it was a
hundred percent I believe fully and Zach
he's gonna do a great job I'm not even
gonna worry about it he's my guy and he
did that over and over and over again um
you know something that fortunately has
been forgotten
drew Brees missed one start to injury in
his career in New Orleans and I gave up
that hit I went through that feeling of
the entire city being upset with you
because you're the guy that got drew
hurt and never at any point has there
ever been any wavering of support from
Drew and I think that it makes you feel
responsible for him and and I think
that's the thing about him that so
specialists he has a way of making the
guys around him love him without trying
his actual personality it's real his
image is not manufactured it just is who
he is he's down-to-earth he's humble and
and on top of the fact and you know one
of the greatest quarterbacks of all time
he's really one of the best people I've
ever been around in my entire life and
it just makes guys want to play for
he's the radio play-by-play announcer
for the New Orleans Saints he'll be on
the call this weekend Rams at Saints
alongside Deuce McAllister but one of
the things to Zach is you also came into
this team with Sean Payton when he
became the head coach and you've seen
him grow not only as a head coach and
then you had those years in which three
straight you know non winning seasons
then last year was sort of the rebound
and then this year a conference
championship what have you seen from
Sean Payton in terms of the leadership
role or just being able to right the
ship and get this team to where it's at
right now you know I think there's a
couple things about Sean that he always
had from day one on is the ability to
know the pulse of his to know where his
guys are at to know what buttons to push
he's a great motivator he's creative
with that stuff he guys believe it you
know it's his personality you know the
whole money thing went you know all over
the place where he brings in you know
225 thousand dollars in cash and says
you want
going through games that's Sean like
that's not a you know there are some
coaches that could do that people guy
can't believe good that there's there's
no question that that's 100% Sean's idea
you know in that moment so that party's
always had but what I think he's evolved
in is and I think it's why the Saints
have kind of got out of that hole of
three straight seven to nine years he's
evolved very much in his understanding I
think of how to win football games you
know this is a team that had always
relied on the passing game almost
exclusively at times at least it felt
like that as offensive linemen and all
of a sudden I think he realized man I've
got a good line I've got these two
really dynamic backs this is a running
football team whether you like it or not
they started building the defense they
started building the team that could win
a different way and I think early in his
career I don't know that he would have
seen that I think that's maturation of
him understanding fully his team and how
to win each individual game in a unique
way you know that fix the opponent I
think that's what's made Bill Belichick
so successful is you know you don't know
one game all sudden they throw the ball
65 times and that's a plan going into a
game and I think Sean is has kind of
learned that over time and I think
that's why the Saints are so successful
in close games in the past two years is
they find ways to win them based on you
know where their advantages are I think
it takes a lot of growth and confidence
as a coach to be willing to change that
week to week you know Zack yeah sterday
I talked about the the walk in which the
opposing team has to take when they get
off the bus they get off the bus you got
to walk all the way across the field to
the opposing locker room and just how
big the the Superdome is when you walk
in there and you'll see anybody in the
stands but kind of helped me out in
terms of you played in that last
conference championship game that was
held there against the Minnesota Vikings
can you describe the environment of not
only that game but what you expect to
see on Sunday yeah so actually before
this season they put a big banner up
there's a big walkway the Superdome is
across the street from the arena so
there's this big walkway they put a big
banner across it this year I think it's
very fitting it says
welcome to your last few moments of
silence and I think that that that is a
pretty true statement I think when you
when you go into the Superdome you know
it's gonna be loud what most people
don't realize is how how loud and how
almost of how much of like almost a
physical nature there is to the noise in
the Superdome you know it's a contained
environment you can feel sound waves
when there's enough of them which is a
pretty unique feeling and I think
there's so much energy the city loves
the Saints so much that in these big
games it is a it's a unique experience
it's almost physical which is strange
you know as a player to feel crowd noise
and you and you can in these games in
the Superdome I know the NFC
Championship in 2009 you know and I've
talked to a bunch of guys about this
last week I think the only exception
that that you'll ever see the Superdome
louder was Steve Gleason's punt block in
the Atlantic game and the Superdome
reopening it's probably the only moment
that the Superdome was ever louder than
it was for the NFC Championship game the
difference was that was a single play in
a single moment the NFC Championship
game was four and a half hours long and
it was like that the entire time so it's
a tough place to play there's been
comments this week that they didn't have
too much trouble with it you know the
last time they came in III would expect
them to this time I know certainly Brett
Favre talked a lot about how hard it was
for them when they came in in 2009 a
couple more for you before we let you go
Zak is it harder to call a game in and
that noise as a play-by-play announcer
when it's that loud and obviously I know
you're feeling during motions as well
how do you kind of taper your emotions
in and talk about what's happening on
the field without getting too overly
excited well but certainly I've learned
something that I that I can trouble with
at times as a matter of fact you guys
play that call and I I've heard it a
bunch this week of Martians interception
and I'm disappointed with it every time
because I couldn't really get as excited
as that moment warranted because I had
already lost my voice you feel that urge
to like you know to be louder right and
as a matter of fact earlier in the game
to touch the 54 yard
the alvin kamara for a touchdown from
Taysom Hill I thought was a great call
but it completely shot my vocal cords
and those are the types of things that
as a young play by play guy I'm learning
and it's not you know certainly not by
any stretch a perfect call every week
but yeah that stuff can that stuff can
be difficult I've gotten advice from a
lot of great broadcasters around the
country that have been really helpful to
me and number one is you know you've
gotta you gotta take a step back and and
be a little more almost reserved in
certain parts of those games otherwise
you know it's all going to be high and
it's all going to be it's almost too
much excitement and certainly your voice
is gonna pay for that and so I'm
learning still that was certainly I know
for every time I hear this week I'm like
I could have been so much better it was
such a big play and I'm up there just
worrying about my voice cracking me
sounds like you've been doing it for
years act by the way so don't even I
loved the emotion and that's the rest of
calls that we get a chance to hear but
trust me we will be listening this
Sunday because this is the game that I
think a lot of people want to see Sean
vs. Sean I think one last question -
everyone keeps talking about the
quarterbacks and the coach and the
offensive are the head coaches but what
about the defensive coordinators -
Dennis Allen Wade Phillips no one talks
about those there has to be some defense
played in this game right Zak yeah and I
would not be surprised at all I like so
many times in my career those games that
you're like oh this is going to be a
shootout that turned into 14 to 12 all
of a sudden you know and and I think
both these defenses listen the Saints
defense has been sensational
since week 10 yeah I mean and and really
back to around week 7
they've been phenomenal they were
phenomenal last week I mean the
Philadelphia Eagles for all the
offensive firepower they have
offensively and as well as they were
playing had 99 yards of offense in the
final three quarters of that game they
completely shut that team down and
they've done that to numerous teams and
and then you look at the Rams who I
think at times this year have struggled
more than people would have thought but
all the sudden in the biggest moment
against Dallas last week they were
dominated so I think these are two
really good defenses I think they're too
underrated
fences and in these big games I just
think you know in the Superdome defense
is gonna reign supreme
more so than people might think in you
know we'll have to wait and see but yeah
I think two very talented groups and
certainly you know the unquestionable
Defensive Player of the Year coming in
on that defensive line and Aaron Donald
will be a tall task for the faint so
Zach bigger party if the Saints win on
Sunday or last Sunday's Drew Brees 40th
birthday party at your at your brewery
yeah I don't know that we're going to
top that this week to be honest with you
know the city will collectively but the
Drew Brees 40th week that the joke of
the night was I hope true breeze turns
40 again next year because we had a
great time and it really worked out well
and it was a great opportunity for us to
kind of also our appreciation to heaven
yeah it was a heck of a night we we
certainly enjoyed it I know they jumped
back into work the next day but uh we
had a good time so if the Saints had
lost last week Zach what the party are
still going on well you would have but I
would be lying if I didn't tell you that
I was sitting in the booth about midway
through the second quarter going this
party is going to be a real debt but
worked out well and it was a that day it
all worked out for itself but look
thanks Zach so much man I appreciate it
best of luck this weekend have a great
call will be listening you induced
McAllister look I can't wait for Sunday
man talk to you soon yeah we can't we
can't either and thank you guys for
asking the Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on audience